Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my Marvel World War Hulk video turns out
they're actually making a World War Hulk movie
finally it's going to be paying off one of the
big teasers during She-Hulk featuring scar
son of Hulk and some of the stuff they've
been setting up in the MCU there was a
bunch of stuff that they set up for the
movies during the She-Hulk series I'll explain
where they're going to be paying all that stuff
off a lot of it will be during the World War
Hulk movie I know I've been away it's a car
for a while I have someone here that I'd
like you all to meet this is my son scar
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos Marvel's
posting a new Ant-Man in the Wasp quantumania
trailer video tonight of course I will do a
video for it but the reports confirm a lot of our
theories in rumors from the past couple of years
about Marvel finally working out their issues with
universal which had previously prevented them from
releasing a solo Hulk movie which is why you saw
so much Hulk just in the Avengers movies that was
their workaround to using the hook instead of
doing Hulk solo movies because originally when
they did Edward Norton's Incredible Hulk it was
planned as a Trilogy of movies for instance the
leader was going to be one of the villains of
the Hulk sequel movie but now they're bringing
him back during Captain America 4 as the main
villain of that movie that's why you saw Tim
Blake Nelson on stage during the Captain America
4 panel of d23 because like he's finally coming
back as a comic book version of the leader he'll
be the main villain of that movie and for the
first time in 14 years coming back to the MCU the
incredible actor Tim Blake Nelson as the leader
Marvel is part of Cinema history and that I get
to be a part of of that uh is an absolute honor
now there's a lot of stuff that's going on during
that movie a lot of Hulk's storyline that they're
paying off during that but not all of it some of
the stuff they were doing during She-Hulk is meant
to be paid off during the World War Hulk movie
there'll be some changes from the comics version
of world war hold just because of what they've
already done in the MCU but it's mostly related
to the plot dealing with scar son of Hulk like
that tag scene at the end of She-Hulk based on
the Marvel Phase 5 movie schedule it would have
to be a Marvel Phase 6 movie or beyond that like
Marvel phase 7 after Avengers Secret Wars and it
sounds like they had a similar situation with a
contract and the rights issues that they had
with doing core X-Men movies right after the
big fox Disney buyout there have been reports a
while ago that Disney wasn't able to do an X-Men
movie right away because some contractual issues
prevented them from doing it up until about the
year 2025 which puts them well into Marvel phase
six so I think that's part of the reason why Kevin
feige is waiting to do the X-Men reboot movie
till around Secret Wars are right after Secret
Wars but during the She-Hulk movie they pay
off this long-running planet Hulk World War
Hulk Storyline by introducing scar son of Hulk
and originally we thought they were just going
to pay that off during Captain America 4 New World
Order in the Thunderbolts movie but turns out that
is meant to be a teaser for a totally separate
Hulk Solo movie their version of world war Hulk
the head writer of She-Hulk revealed that during
the first few episodes we see Bruce Banner Hulk
versus She-Hulk scenes with him losing it a
little bit in the ship from sakar they came
to bring him to his son's scar as we know now and
that was meant to be part of a larger Movie teaser
that they never fully intended on finishing or
paying off during the series like it was meant
to specifically set up totally separate movies
that they hadn't announced yet at the time part
of that was Captain America 4 New World Order and
part of that was the Hulk Solo movie there was the
whole subplot with them stealing the powers
of the Hulk using their blood like stealing
their gamma Powers they used some of that for the
Intelligentsia plot in the Todd Hulk stuff but it
was also meant to set up the idea of Thunderbolt
Austin Val being able to steal the game of powers
of the Hulk finally like Thunderbolt Ross been
trying to do it this entire time in the MCU
and using that to turn Thunderbolt Ross into a
version of Red Hulk which is supposed to happen
during Captain America 4 New World Order and you
kind of see the connection here with the leader
being the main villain of Captain America four
like he's probably the person that Val uses to
take the gamma powers of the Hulk and give them
to Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk because sampling
Hulk's blood and recreating his powers using the
same gamma experiment were all part of his thing
during The Incredible Hulk movie there's been lots
of rumors about what his Red Hulk is going to look
like like how they're going to personify him how
he's going to behave in the MCU and it sounds like
he's actually going to be a little bit more like
the job fix it version of Hulk and I think what
they really mean by that is that he's just going
to be the more chatty version of the Hulk the more
acerbic version because the Joe Fix It version
of The Hulk in the comics was kind of like the
dirt bag version of The Hulk and was way more
chatty when they were doing special effects for
Avengers Age of Ultron they actually accidentally
wound up doing a version of Gray Hulk that they
then took back like they kind of deleted when
he was fighting Iron Man in the Hulkbuster they
basically just hooked him out so much like he went
so crazy that he started to look visually gray on
screen in jaw Sweden at the time was like let's
pull that back a little bit and they can just
use Gray Hulk in the future of the movies if they
ever want to look they didn't want to use Avengers
Age of Ultron to waste their Gray Hulk moment
if they were gonna use it for something much
bigger but previously we thought that they were
going to pay off all this scar son of Hulk stuff
they would just give whatever parts that they were
planning for the character to someone else like
Val like they would just give Thunderbolt Ross's
parts to Val because she's already become very
powerful within the US government as of black
panther wakanda forever she's the director of
the CIA but now turns out they recast because
they wanted to do so much red Hulk stuff like
not just like a little little bit it's not just a
teaser like a lot of Red Hulk stuff it sounds like
they're just gonna tease Red Hulk during Captain
America four like you see it briefly then they'll
pay it off in a much bigger way during a World
War Hulk movie where you see Bruce Banner Hulk
versus Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk like Hulk versus
Red Hulk finally that they've been teasing this
whole time like this whole time Thunderbolt Ross
has said that he wanted to take the powers of the
Hulk he was so sure of what he was on to that he
tested it on himself and something went very wrong
or it went very right whereas
I'm concerned that man's whole
body is property of the US Army God damn it why
the funny thing about that original Incredible
Hulk movie is that Thunderbolt Ross revealed that
he was responsible for creating the weapons plus
program like it was originally the super soldier
program then the military just evolved it into
the weapons plus program that's where they came up
with a super soldier serum that they gave to the
Abomination they continued that plot during Falcon
and Winter Soldier with a more upgraded version
of the super soldier serum but also during the
events of Incredible Hulk are predating the events
of the movie when Hulk had his gamma accident he
was actually working secretly on the weapons plus
program Thunderbolt Ross just lied to him and told
him he was working on something totally different
so Thunderbolt Ross had always planned on using
the Hulk's research to create the next weapons
plus turns out he's going to wind up using it
on himself the other cool thing about that too is
that Val is kind of taking over the weapons plus
program that's kind of her purview and that's how
they're supposed to be creating the Sentry in the
MCU because he's part of the weapons Plus in the
comics and they'll pay that plot off during the
Thunderbolts movie like the century is meant to
be one of the main villains of the Thunderbolts
movie but that's because he starts to go crazy
because of the Void personality I've already done
a completely separate Sentry video so I'll post
links for that in the description below but Val
taking over the weapons plus program makes sense
because that's how they get to Weapon X and they
do the new MCU version of Wolverine after Hugh
Jackman shows up and does his classic version of
Wolverine there's also some other stuff that
they're using to set that up too like in the
Thunderbolts movie they're going to introduce the
concept of adamantium in the MCU using some of the
eternals Easter eggs in The Eternal that is
literally stuck in the Indian Ocean now just
jutting out of the planet so there's a lot of
really big story lines that people have been
waiting for that they're using some of these
movies to pay off but one of the big questions
about this world war Hulk movie is how close
to the comics it's going to be because in the
comics World War Hook was basically Bruce Banner
coming to wage war on the Illuminati which they
did during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
but it sounds like they're not going to be doing
that part of the storyline in the movies just
because we don't have that team inside the 616
MCU Universe the appointed during World War
Hulk though is it's basically the Hulk versus
everyone the heroes and the villains and if they
do wind up doing something like that in the world
war Hulk movie what is it that makes him that mad
because his whole idea during She-Hulk in the last
couple of movies is that he's super Zen now like
he's meant to be the professor Hulk version who's
completely balanced both of his personas what's
gonna happen to drive him to full world breaker
Hulk State and it sounds like it's gonna have
something to do with valon Thunderbolt Ross doing
something to his son during the comic book version
though he gets so mad that he wipes the floor with
pretty much everybody even the Sentry now like
he doesn't defeat the Sentry they're so powerful
both of them that they basically fight each other
until they get too tired to keep fighting it'd be
kind of like Wolverine and Deadpool going at each
other like they heal so fast that no matter how
many body parts they hacked off they would just
instantly heal everything in the fight would just
continue until they got too tired to keep fighting
their couple characters like that with the Hulk
that are so powerful that they fight each other
to stand Stills I don't know how much longer Mark
Ruffalo is planning on playing the Hulk but
I do believe that they're going to do a Young
Avengers project at some point or like an Avengers
Academy project and Scar will be the Hulk during
that like we have a Hulk but he just happens
to be the son of the Hulk I will say there's
one thing they have to do before Mark Ruffalo
leaves the MCU is to have Wolverine versus Hulk
I'll be so salty if they don't actually do that
in the MCU at some point the funny thing though
is you rewind a couple years you might remember
Mark Ruffalo complaining about Universal hating
money and not wanting to do a Hulk Solo movie with
them I think at the time what was going on there
is that Universal didn't want to sign the rights
away or part of the rights away to Marvel they
didn't want to give some of the potential money
away and that's why Marvel did not do a Hulk Solo
movie before this because if they did they'd be
forced to let Universal distribute it and take
way more profits than they wanted to let them have
and it sounds like whatever was going on before
Marvel literally just sat and waited out until the
contract expired and that's when they're going to
do that World War Hulk movie everyone let me know
in the comments though what do you actually want
them to do during the World War Hulk movie my next
big video will be for that brand new Ant-Man and
the Wasp Quantumania trailer you can click here
to watch that I'll update the link as soon as I
post it and click here for that Daredevil Born
Again first look at Jessica Jones coming back in
the MCU thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!